it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games and new releases
and this week you worked tirelessly to
take down Pudge and protect this
carriage in the contents within it but
just as the world seems incredibly
hopeless it turns out that you can fly
and your party is incredibly overpowered
if you like what you see in this trailer
then prepare for a traditional top-down
action RPG that looks nothing like this
the arcade hack and slash functions with
up to four players choose a hero and
fight cooperatively against the rise of
evil which I can only assume is a
trailer that has zero gameplay also you
heartlessly sacrifice your clones in the
swapper which duplicates itself from pc
to console this week toss soulless
bodies into bottomless pits to progress
throughout the story you can obtain orbs
throughout the game but the story itself
is actually worth exploring on its own
and all the art is constructed from clay
models resulting in a beautiful game
that's also creepy and weird if you
never tried it on PC it's worth a go
this time around and the mystery begins
August fifth now let's take a walk to a
strange world of data and pie charts
where you have the right to tell the
world that you are not a statistic Metro
is ethereal whimsical and highly praised
if you have a Vita it's recommended
raise the bar graph August fifth
continuing on this week's path of
strange and beautiful we get road not
taken a randomly generated roguelike
puzzler where you genuinely look like a
rogue after a wicked storm you try to
reconnect children and villagers to the
ones they love but when the two roads
diverged in a yellow wood which path
will you take take the road less
traveled by August fifth
and we finish off with a three versus
one brutal dungeon crawler where your
friends get to act like the monsters you
knew they always were if a friend kills
you they take your place and try to
finish the dungeon you don't let them
make you look like a fool murder your
pals and make them rue the day they ever
met you friends become enemies august
six for further details visit gamespot's
new releases page release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week